Community Pride on 8 news now is
sponsored by Our Community Pride
Partners Finley Automotive Group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care and
Silver State Schools Credit Union
well Southwest Medical the sponsors of
this segment is hosting its national day
of giving tomorrow Rocky spoke with the
doctor to get the details
you know we've been celebrating
Southwest Medical's 50-year anniversary
and every time we're giving back or you
know spreading awareness about a
different organization and this time
we're talking about the national day of
giving tomorrow
awesome thank you you know what
Southwest Medical we have been
celebrating this year our 50th year in
southern Nevada uh contributing to the
health of our community but even more so
really just contributing back to the
community and willing to step out and
find where needs are needing to be met
in our community and finding ways to to
partner with other associations to meet
those needs
and this time around we've got straight
from the street so explain how we're
giving back to them and and what's the
call to action tomorrow
so uh straight to the street is uh
really an organization that helps
support and uh
people who are homeless in southern
Nevada advocating for job training uh
community outreach Social Security
benefits any of the needs that can help
somebody who wants to get off the
streets to uh to get off the streets or
uh call is to uh really be able to uh
help I know through our different events
at Thanksgiving our organization is
already brought in needs for people that
will help them get off the street
whether that's some food some clothing
some Financial uh donations so any way
that people can help straight from the
streets were greatly appreciative now
there are other there are other
organizations in the community that will
benefit from tomorrow's national day of
giving can you give us a little preview
of the other ones
so uh being in the community and
entrenched our community for so long
Southwest Medical is really uh build
alliances that a lot of the
organizations in uh Southern uh
Nevada whether it's the ALS of Nevada
the American Lung Association the Down
Syndrome organization of Southern Nevada
and down syndrome connections the
College of Southern Nevada Foundation
Special Olympics Three Square active and
on the board with Tyler Robinson
foundation and so so many more
organizations which I can't uh go
through all the entire list now but very
very involved with many of the
organizations throughout our community
absolutely well congratulations again on
the 50th anniversary for Southwest
Medical this is a great way to kind of
culminate everything for the national
day of giving tomorrow so get out there
and give back if you want to uh donate
to straight in the streets uh you can go
to their website at
straightfromthestreets.org and figure
out ways to get involved with them and
uh what they're bringing to our
community and how they're trying to help
people in southern Nevada